we're on the last section of the last
test so this is the home stretch problem
one a restaurant menu lists eight
dinners and three desserts how many
different dinner dessert combinations
are possible from this menu so you have
eight dinners and for each of them you
can have three different desserts all
right so it's eight times three
combinations and that's 24 and you can
list them all out right for dinner one
you could have one two three desserts
for dinner do you can have one two three
desserts so you would have three for
each of the eight three possible
desserts so that's how you get to 24
problem to the sum of 3x + 5 the sum of
3x + 5 is equal is equal to the product
the product of x times one-third so I
just wrote it I mean I read it and while
I read it I wrote it out the sum of 3x +
5 is equal to the product of X and
one-third which of the following
equations gives a relationship stated in
the problem above well exactly as I
wrote it that's choice e right x times
one-third that's the same thing as
one-third X right so that's one-third X
so that's choice e problem three problem
three let me see if I can do it right
here a clerk accidentally threw a
valuable document into one of 90 trash
cans all right one of 90 trash cans or
let's say there are 90 trash cans it is
equally likely the document is in any
one of these 90 trash cans if of exactly
15 of these 90 trash cans are blue what
is the probability that the document
will be in a blue trash can well it's 15
of these 90 are blue so the probability
is going to be in one of those 15 is
going to be essentially 15 over 90 how
do I know that well there's 100
probability there's one hundred percent
probabilities in one of the 90 right and
so if I want to know what's probability
it's in one of the blue I take the
fraction of the blue over the hole and
that's the probability that it's in one
of the blue trash cans and if i divide
the top and the bottom let's see 15 goes
into 90 15 goes into 32 times because in
96 x so this is one or
six just divide the numerator and
denominator by 15 and that's choice C
next problem problem for how many
different integer pairs satisfy the
equation x over Y is equal to one half
so another way of writing this you could
say that x is equal to one-half why i
just multiply both sides by Y or you can
multiply both sides by 2 and you say 2x
is equal to Y so how many integer pairs
satisfy this well any integer I've put
in here I can get I double it and i get
y so what are the pairs one due to four
three three six four eight five ten i
can their infinite I can keep going so
the answer is more than four I mean I
listed more than four just in the span
of about five seconds so the answer is
definitely either infinite integer pairs
that satisfy that equation next problem
problem five I have to do let me see
where they asking first according to the
graph above during which of the
following two months appear to month
periods did Ellen's bookstore sell the
least number of books a two month period
interesting so let's draw the graph and
so this is June July August September
october november and it's 10 20 30 40
and i'm going to try to draw it as best
as they drew it if this is I can so June
looks like they sold a little under I
don't know 10 books June look something
like like that july they sold a ton they
sold 40 books looks like so July looks
something like that August they sold
exactly 10 books it looks like I just
eyeball it august-september looks like
30 little over 30 Timbers
there October is like 25 October's 25
and then November November is 30
remember looks about 30 so they say
during which of the following two month
periods did Ellen's books or sell the
least number of books so let's look at
the choices choice a choice a is June
and July whoops choice a is June and
July so how many books that you sell in
June July we can I but let's say let's
say that this is seven and this is 40 so
this is going to be 47 July and August
so July and August is this period july
and august so i can already tell you
that July and August is going to be
higher than June and July why because
autist is higher than June all right so
August looks like 10 this looks like 40
so this is going to be 50 and then if we
look at augustana humber august and sep
tember august and September's this month
period so if we say that this is 10 and
that looks like about I don't know 30 33
so what's 10 + 33 it's 43 so that's our
winner so far and then they're asking
september-october let me switch colors
september-october would be that that's
33 October looks like about 25 it's a
little luck approximation just what's 33
plus 25 that's 58 that's actually the
most so far and then finally october and
november october november november looks
like 30 so what's 30 plus 25 it's 55 so
the smallest is definitely august and
sep tember next problem maybe we'll
stick with this white let's see 6
problem 6 okay they drew us a line they
say that this
it's point a this is point B this is
point C and the figure above AC equals
24 AC is equal to 24 they tell us that a
b is equal to b c a b is equal to BC so
this side this leg has to equal that
length and combine the add up to 24 so
we know that that's going to be 12 and
that's also going to be 12 I could have
to add up to 24 and they're equal point
D not shown is on the line between a and
B so point D is someplace here such that
ad is equal to D be so if we put D here
let me do a different color if this is d
they want us so 12 is this whole length
this whole length is 12 they're saying
ad is equal to D be so what is what are
each of these smaller lengths going to
be equal this is equal to this so this
is going to be 6 and this is going to
have to be six right because this two
sides are equal and the two lengths are
equal to add up to 12 now what are they
asking what is d c equals so what is
this distance just to hear from there to
there ok so we'd have to go six to get
to be so six to get to be and then we'd
have to go 12 more to get to c 6 plus 12
and then gets 18 so this distance is 18
not too bad this problem that's but
let's answer D problem seven problem
seven if n is a positive integer then
six times n a 10 to the negative n plus
plus 1 times 10 to the negative and must
equal 1 so let's simplify this is
essentially this is I mean they wrote a
little complicated but that we have six
tends to the negative end here and then
we have one more right I mean six times
ten the negative n you could rewrite
this as 10 to the negative n plus 10 to
the negative n plus 10 to the negative
n + 10 to the negative end now that I
recommend you to do this on the exam 10
to the negative n let's 10 to the
negative n how many have i drawn one two
three four five six right that's six to
the negative six times ten to the
negative n and to that we add one more
10 to the negative n so how many 10 to
the negative ends do we have we have
seven now all right so it's seven times
10 to the negative n and that is not a
choice so what's another way of writing
10 to the negative end well that's the
same thing as 1 over 10 to the N so
that's seven times 1 over 10 to the N
which is of course equal 27 / 10 to the
N and that is choice B next problem
actually I'll do it in the next video
because i only have i have less than a
minute left I'll see you soon